welcome to this video playing silver
with black Silvo ok we have a modern
defense see can I go with B five now
maybe really just playing this some by
en Knight f6 going for C 50 e 5 as usual
plate instantly like it's the most
normal thing in the world I will win e5
no yes
yeah he just blend it is his most
important central porn by pushing you
five in one second okay H for chow maybe
age five is some somewhat dangerous so
why not this also introduces the idea to
play Knight g4 some time looking at the
bishop only three and threatening to
take even more material ok but just
castle it can castle long may be
wondering about that
what should I take on d4 first make sure
that the bishop actually captures them
maybe not a bad idea and then go from
here that's better and I cannot play
this without castling knowledge the
problem is that he's still quite active
still quite active yeah and the queen is
supposed to the rook so I probably
should move the Queen somewhere maybe
here okay so that i can play c5c 595 is
now a pretty substantial threat
and after c5 he definitely doesn't want
to take on f6 yeah it's not somewhat
messy I mean you just blunder tizzy porn
but it's still not totally simple
position okay winning spatium should be
okay
yeah we got we get opposite color to
bishops now but my bishop won't have sex
is not really bear down okay it's not
taking Queen f5 maybe yeah that's not
bad I'm Queen a five-night of seven
maybe but ya can do that
we add kind of tactics that are
sometimes possible so preparing doing
here getting the rock out of out of the
attack from the Queen and covering e7 I
would like to play Queen a fire
activating my queen taking here yeah but
I don't mind him to take a6 very much it
also opened up a little bit of the a
file uh huh interesting now I didn't
think about that move at all e six CS
night takes is six huh okay ye five is
ugly but I don't see how I protected
otherwise I have bishop age six as an
idea however and he pre he did something
about it okay
look aged three maybe this kind of thing
no just just retreating okay let's keep
this pawn what is the time one minute
down and not so great one down he's
close to taking this 25
yeah at the moment I'm my point is not
really held I mean maybe I should play a
foil and Bishop g7 me check
I don't know if this is leading to
anything Queen ADA but that's not even
threatening anything at least I don't
see it yahoo group h eight maybe this
isn't I'm learning and now he's
threatening something I playing this
like a total [ __ ] yo check and the
worst is the time okay I need to go for
counter a checker also not not just
sitting around you has a check here I
can go to g5 where the king is
relatively safe
okay I just needed to play a quick move
IAM his queen is not doing that much at
the moment it's a little bit a little
bit of side takes Knight X is rather
problematic film c2c for everything
hangs
let's grab the grab the Queen check
check check and this rook check check
check check check check check
check check okay this was another chick
made yeah I mean it's kind of checkmate
okay whoo-chow it was surprisingly
tricky after he just blundered his most
important on but he still had some some
ways to to irritate maybe maybe I
shouldn't have played h5 I don't know I
don't know h5 is not totally necessary i
guess but still I mean it's it just a
good position for black maybe he's six I
wanted this this possibility but this is
got a little bit tricky now because II
five is an ugly move really the computer
suggest this this is much stronger yeah
this is much stronger that has has this
Knight e5 idea and I'm still covering
here with Queen and rook yeah this is
better if I has a move that really is
ugly but I didn't see another way to
safely protect the c5 as a move that
looks weird because it leaves this wide
open and here I don't know this is scott
really tricky i owe you for strong and i
guess i'm somewhat in control and now
here we are the computer gives me a
pretty pretty big edge now but Jan of
course it is so this tricky take stakes
here and this is a draw it seems or not
check
this is a mistake Queen a six is better
or look T one Queen age 66 Dallas is
better because it gets a tempo here no
this is given by the comp as equal wild
stuff no not sure what had happened them
here a king g5 is even the strongest
move I just wanted to capture on f 2
when the kicking is relatively safe down
I mean and after this I'm probably
somehow winning right a queen d 4 is
good but III is also I III is actually
the strongest okay yeah he can give this
check yet I'm just I'm just running that
something going on I know I mean this is
too much hangs thanks this hangs and so
on the updates too much alright thanks
for watching